Here's 30 tips to help you master
creating AI videos using Google Veo3.
Whether you're a total beginner or an
advanced user, I guarantee that you'll
find something in this tutorial to help
you level up your AI videos. Tip number
one, you can create these vlog style
videos of a talking character such as a
white yeti simply by using the prompt
self camera angle shot from an extended
arm. Then we need to fill in the rest of
the details. So, I added that it's a
Yeti with wife for holding up a fish.
He's in an icy landscape. Below that, I
also gave it some dialogue for the
character to say, like, "Welcome back to
Yeti Adventures. Today, we're learning
how to go ice fishing." By the way, this
is all done inside the text video
generator. Welcome back to Yeti
Adventures. And today we're learning how
to go ice fishing. Now, for a complete
vlog video, we also need some different
camera angles. So, we can try a
different prompt of holding up a vlog
cam on a selfie stick. He is talking to
the vlog cam. I've been out here since
sunrise. Just me. No internet trolls
asking if I'm related to Bigfoot.
We can also use the camera angle in the
prompt. Shot from a vlog camera. This
will give us a full wide angle
perspective of the yeti doing whatever
activities he's doing. In this case,
she's smashing a hole through an icy
lake. Of
course, we can use all sorts of
different characters. For example, a
stormtrooper in our vlogs. Morning,
trooper squad. Just polished the armor.
Got to keep that Imperial shine. Tip
number two, create man on the street
style interviews simply by using the
phrase man on the street. I just start
my prompt with a man on the street
interview. Inside Gotham City, a young
female reporter askked a young man what
he thinks about Batman. The young man is
unhappy with how many problems Batman
causes. What are your thoughts on
Batman? Honestly, he causes more
problems than he solves. This city's a
mess because of him. Now, in Sodom
Prompts, we can also specifically tell
each character the exact dialogue we
want them to say. For this example,
where I'm having a Stormtrooper reporter
interviewing a Sith, I specifically want
a script for each character to say. For
the Stormtrooper reporter, I tell him to
say, "Are the rumors about the war in
the outer rim true?" And for the male
Sith, I'll specifically tell him to say,
"The Outer Rim is ripe for conquest. The
Empire always expands." Are the rumors
about war in the Outer Rim true? The
Outer Rim is ripe for conquest. The
Empire always expands.
It's important that you're clear in
specifically what part of the dialogue
is attributed to each character in the
shot. Tip number three, removing the
subtitles. You've probably noticed that
in the videos I've generated, there are
subtitles at the bottom that pop up
frequently. This is kind of a problem in
Google Veil right now. I've seen
different pieces of advice of how to get
rid of the subtitles. For example, I've
heard people say in the prompt, don't
use quotation marks when describing what
you want them to say. I've also heard
people say add phrases like no subtitles
to your prompts. But I've tried these
all. none of them work consistently,
you're frequently still going to get
these subtitle captions at the bottom of
your videos. There's a couple different
ways of doing this, although none of
them are ideal. So, one option is you
can go inside a video editor and crop
out the part where the subtitles appear.
So, in this video, the subtitles appear
at the bottom. I can zoom out, increase
the size of the video, and then hide the
part with the subtitles. That imperial
shine. Remember, cleanliness is next to
loyalty. Another option is to use an AI
subtitle remover. I tried a couple
different ones. V-Make has a decent one.
So, if we go and use the video subtitle
remover, and let's go ahead and upload
the video with the subtitles that we
want to get rid of. And you can see
these subtitle captions appearing at the
bottom. It'll take a minute to process
the video and clean up the subtitles for
us. Now, if you're using the free
version, you do get to preview a 5second
video. Morning, trooper squad. Just
polished the armor. Got to keep that
Imperial shine. And you'll see that at
the bottom, subtitles have been cleanly
removed. Now, if you're going to be
using their free version, you might need
to chalk your video up into different
parts to get the subtitles removed in
all of it. Um, but I just paid for
whatever the subscription was. Tip
number four, you can add in accents for
your characters when they're speaking.
Adding in the accents isn't as simple as
just writing it into the prompt. You
need to consider whether it's plausible
in the environment for that character to
have the accent. For example, if I try
to generate a Star Wars character with a
Hispanic accent, here's what it turns
out to sound like. Mercy is a lie the
weak tell themselves.
Power speaks. That doesn't sound like
the character has an accent at all. The
reason is because inside a Star Wars
movie, there's never really any
characters with accents like this.
However, if we change the environment,
for example, a medieval monastery, we
can easily introduce a British accent
into there since that's very plausible
based on movies and films. They don't
just take gold, they take souls. Burn
the churches, mock the cross, laugh as
we scream. The location of where you
generate your video contributes to
whether or not the character has an
accent in the video or not. I generated
a video of a Brazilian man inside a
store in New York City. He's just going
to sound like a regular American guy.
Good morning. Can I get a ham and cheese
on a roll toasted
and make it with a smile like yours?
However, if I generate a video of a
Brazilian man on a beach in Rio de
Janeiro, listen to what this sounds
like.
[Music]
It gave him so much of an accent that it
actually change the language that he's
speaking in. Tip number five, you can
control the tone of voice that the
characters speak with. For example, I
can ask for a Viking commander to
aggressively shout and command his
troops. Warriors to the monastery.
Take it down. We can also go the
opposite way and generate a character
that's nervous, stuttering, and unsure
of himself. The they're the Vikings.
They're they're coming.
I I saw them.
Hundreds.
Now, when it comes to controlling the
tone of voice, I found that this works
much better if you don't have a specific
script that you want your character to
follow and instead just describe the
general idea of what they should be
talking about. Here I've got this old
man whispering about what it was like to
fight back in the day. Fighting
alongside Lord Nounaga. Those were days
of fire and steel.
We carved a path through chaos. Tip
number six, adding ambient sounds into
the background. Here I got a woman at
the beach in Brazil. And in the prank, I
specifically told it to generate the
sound of waves at the beach.
Oh, you guys are too funny.
Come on, let's go for a swim.
This is another example of her walking
through a forest with a sound of a creek
running by.
And here's an example of the Brazilian
man again, except this time in the
prompt, I specifically asked for there
to be the sounds of wind rustling and
cars honking in the background.
calling.
By adding in these ambient sounds, you
create a video that's more immersive. By
the way, if there's any Brazilians
watching, tell me down in the comments
what this guy is saying. I'm curious to
find out. Tip number seven. In addition
to ambient sounds, you can also
specifically prompt for the types of
music that you want to hear in the
background. You can prompt for
suspenseful and thrilling music.
We can also prompt for a more relaxed
piano playing in the background.
Be specific in exactly the instruments
that you described. In this prompt, I
specifically told there to be a guing
playing in the background, which is a
traditional Chinese instrument. Not
something that you'd usually expect an
AI video to be able to generate.
Tip number eight, upscaling your videos
to a full HD resolution is free if you
have a subscription to Google Veil 3.
All you have to do is go to this
download button and then select the
upscaled version and Veil 3 will go
ahead and upscale the video from 720
which is what it generates the videos in
up to 1080p. This takes a couple
minutes. Now the upscaled video quality
is okay. It's not great. It's not the
best upscaler in the world. If you look
at it closely, there's a little bit of
graininess in the bamboo in the
background. for example, her face also
isn't that detailed, but it's cool that
it's a bonus feature that we get inside
video 3. Tip number eight, use Flow TV
to find inspiration for your prompts.
Inside the Flow interface, we can go to
watch Flow TV up here at the top. And
here, Google V3 has a bunch of videos
that's recommended to us. Now below we
can use show prompt and it'll actually
show us the exact prompt used to
generate these videos. These were done
using Google video 2. Uh so it's not the
most recent Google video 3 model but you
can still get inspiration from this. If
we go to the grid view we can see the
full assortment of videos. But these are
some pretty interesting looking videos.
You can also flip through the different
channels. And this is a really, really
cool way to get inspiration for your
prompts. Tip number 10. Can we make
vertical videos inside Google Veil 3?
I'm sure a lot of you shorts creators
are curious about this. If we look
inside the Veil 3 prompting interface
and scroll through the settings, it
doesn't really look like there's a place
for us to make vertical videos, but we
can actually use the frames to video,
which lets us attach a reference image
to create the vertical videos. This is
actually really really cool. What I've
done here is I've taken a originally
vertical image of this uh character
riding on a horse and I actually rotated
it 90° so that now it's a full
widescreen image. I'll upload this
widescreen image that's rotated 90° into
Google Veo 3. So let's go to the image
uploader and we can upload that rotated
vertical image of him. Let's put that in
there. And then the prompt just describe
it roughly. It rides the horse. Now, if
we generate this image, Voil 3 can
actually animate a 90° rotated image,
believe it or not. So, using this
method, you can actually create good
resolution vertical videos. All you have
to do is rotate the images, generate the
videos, and then rotate the videos back
into a vertical video. I created a bunch
of them for this character. So, how do
we get videos of a consistent character
like I'm showing you here? Well, there's
a couple of different methods to do it
in video 3. I'll show you four different
ways. Tip number 11, generating
consistent characters using text video.
For this method, we're simply going to
be using the text prompt to generate a
consistent character. The key to this is
we'll need a very, very detailed
description of our character's
appearance. as details as you can get.
Actually, in this case, I asked for a
female warrior with pale skin and long
white braided hair braided into two
thick plates that hang over her
shoulders. She wears a dark red cloak
with loose white trousers and strap
leather gear around her waist. She
carries a short straight sword. So,
that's going to be the character
description. Notice how I talked about
the physical appearance, her hair, her
skin, uh the clothing that she wears,
and then below that we can describe
what's going on in that specific scene.
So, here it's snowing and I want a
close-up shot on her face as she quietly
whispers about trying to find her sister
again. I will find my sister.
I have to find her again. Now, if I want
to generate more videos of the same
character, I need to start by pasting in
the same exact character description I
used earlier. Except this time, I'll
just describe the different scene I want
her to appear in. She's climbing up the
stairs to a dark tower. A look of
intensity on her face, clenched teeth.
It's cold and snowing,
[Music]
so it didn't follow the prompt exactly.
She's not climbing up the stairs. She's
kind of looks like she's actually coming
down a well, but the character
appearance stays fairly similar. Now,
this isn't going to be a perfect method.
There's going to be some inconsistencies
from video to video. If you compare
these two videos side by side, you'll
see that the clothing isn't exactly the
same. The facial structure is slightly
different and her hair braid comes over
a different shoulder. But the benefit of
using text to video for your consistent
characters is that it can use all the
features of Google V3 including making
your character talk. But there are other
methods to get consistent characters.
Tip number 12, using the green screen
hack. This method came from Martin
Nebolon. Make sure you go and check out
his Twitter. But in this case, what
we'll need is an image of our character
with a green screen behind her. What
we're going to do is actually go to
frames to video. Let me get rid of this
prompt. Then we'll upload in that image
of our character with a green screen
behind her. Then in the prompt, start it
with instantly jump/cut to on frame one.
This is what's going to give us a
consistent character. After that, just
putting what you want to happen in the
scene. Uh, she walks next to a huge
white direwolf in an icy landscape. It
is snowing. And if we take a look at
some of the results I've gotten using
this method, you'll see that the first
frame starts with a character and a
green screen behind her. If we go ahead
and play this video,
it'll cut to a new scene of that
character just like how we described it
in the prompt. There are some other
examples I made for her.
[Music]
I mean, the quality of these videos
aren't going to be as high as using just
the text prompt. You can see for some of
these, the contrast is extra extra high
in it, but it will do a decent job of
mapping our character into the scene.
Right now in Google Vo 3, there's no way
to generate dialogue for the character
when you're using a reference image. So
these shots won't include the character
speaking. Tip number 13, using Veil 3
ingredients to create a consistent
character. This is going to be the third
way of creating a consistent character.
So below frames to video, we have
ingredients to video. Underneath here,
we can upload a bunch of different
images that we want to combine into the
same video. So, for example, I can
upload an image of my character. This
time I'm using a white background. Let's
upload a different character also. Um,
how about this orc? And I also uploaded
an image for the landscape I want them
to be walking on. And let's say the
female warrior walks next to the orc on
the rocky landscape.
Then if we go and generate this video,
you'll see at the top it says switching
to a compatible model for this feature.
That's because this ingredients to video
feature only works with the older
version of Google VO2. It won't
technically work with the newest Google
V3 model, but let's try it anyways. So
the results don't necessarily look
amazing. It looks like at the end it
kind of swaps to a different scene of
the female character walking by herself.
So, this isn't necessarily the best way
to get a consistent character either.
And it's also using the older Google V2
model, so you don't get all the benefits
like the AI generated sounds that go
along with your video. So, what's
actually the best way to get videos of a
consistent character that look the same
from scene to scene? Well, the way to do
this is to use image to video where we
create the images of our consistent
character first and then animate them
into a video, which is tip number 14.
So, I'll start with this picture of our
female character again. And what I'll do
is upload that image into the Flux
context image generator.
There she is. And now all I'll need to
do is to directly tell the AI chatbot
how to create a new image of this
consistent character. So inside the chat
box, I'll tell the AI image generator,
create an image of this female character
in a medieval tab. Her appearance should
stay the same. Cinematic film shot on a
Sony camera. And it does a great job of
putting out consistent character into a
new image. Let's do a before and after
comparison. Now, the shading in that
photo is a little darker, which is kind
of what I wanted anyways for a more
cinematic type of image, but let's see
how close the physical appearance is.
Starting with the hair and the face
area, the braids that she's got over her
back and over her and over her shoulder
are copied into the image. Her face also
looks pretty much the same. Uh, if we go
down and look through her accessories
and clothing, her belt, the trousers
that she's wearing, the cloak, the
sword, everything matches up. I also
create a couple more images of this
character. I'll tell the chatbot, create
a close-up shot on this female
character's face in the same scene. I
mean, in the original image, you can't
really see the face of the character
that clearly. So, the AI had to use its
imagination a little bit more to fill in
what's missing. But now that we have
these images generated, we can turn them
into AI videos. Back inside Google Vo 3,
make sure you have frames to video
selected, which will let us put in a
reference image of our character.
There's one of her full body shot. And
in the prompt, I'll just tell her to
walk forward and raise her sword.
I generated a couple more shots of this
character. We can see her looking around
the empty town.
Now, as a bonus tip, you can also use
frame interpolation. What that means is
we can upload the first frame we want.
So, for example, this close-up shot of
the woman's face. And let's also upload
a last frame for the generated video.
this time a bird's eye view shot of her.
And then in the prompt, if we put in
something like the camera pose back,
what the video generator will do was
generate a video that starts with the
first frame of a character and ends with
this last image frame that we put into
here. This is a really great way to
control the camera movement in your
scenes.
Now, the main issue with this again is
that technically this feature only works
with the older Google V2 model. So, it
won't be able to generate any sound
effects or anything like that. Now, if
you want to try out the Flux context
model to create the images of the
consistent character for yourself, the
way I'm doing it is using this image
platform called Open Art, uh starting
from the Open Art homepage, go to create
image. From there, you'll see this chat
toedit feature. Click on that. And then
inside we have the option to use a bunch
of different image generators. The new
flux context max model is what I used.
I'll put the links in the description if
you want to go try it out. Tip number
15, adding lip sync to your characters
to generate dialogue. The main
limitation of using this method to
create a consistent character is that
when you're using a reference image in
Google VO3, it can't actually generate
character dialogue for you. So, if we
actually want our character to be
speaking, we'll have to use an external
AA app to make that happen. There's some
different websites where you can do this
from. One place that I like to use for
lip syncing videos is a website called
Design. Inside there, they have this lip
sync. If you try this, we can upload an
image of our character. I've uploaded
this uh video of the female character
that we generated in Veo 3. And now
let's adding a voice. So I'll upload my
own audio file. Uh since I already
generated that. All right, let's see
what it comes up with. It's finished
generating. So let's take a look. We
call them monsters.
But when I looked into the eyes of the
last one I slayed,
I saw sorrow. Okay, so obviously this is
not the ideal solution. It would be much
better if we could just directly do this
inside Veo 3, but for now this is a
workaround we can use. Tip number 16,
creating videos of consistent objects or
products inside Google Veo 3. Just like
how we generated the images of a
consistent character first, we can also
generate images of a consistent product
or an object or a location. Again, I'm
using the Flux context AI image
generator, and I want to generate more
images of this specific product. I can
simply go and tell the AI, create a side
profile photo of a young Canadian man
wearing the blue headphones. The gold
patterns on the headphones should remain
the same on a street in Montreal shot on
a Sony camera. And the AI bots able to
put the exact headphones onto a model
for us. Do a quick inspection. The gold
and blue colors look the same, but I
want to look a little bit closer at how
refined the details are. So, this main
logo looks very, very, very similar.
These little blotches of gold, these
mini patterns that go across the
headphones also look the same. And when
we have the images of a consistent
product, we can simply animate that into
a video inside Google Veil 3.
[Music]
Tip number 17, creating fight scenes.
Google V3 is incredible at animating
live character animations, and it's
gotten pretty good at creating fight
scenes. Also, it's as easy as putting
the words uh kung fu fight scene inside
your prompt, for example. A lot of these
videos start off kind of slow, but as
the video goes on, you can see it turns
into a much more dynamic action scene.
Here's a lightsaber d I created that has
the same thing going on. In the
beginning, it starts off kind of slow
and then turns into a very, very dynamic
action scene. Again, if you want to try
to put a specific character inside the
fight scenes, in the prompt, describe
the exact appearance of that character.
For here, I described the appearance of
the female warrior that I showed
earlier. And then in the prompt, I
describe what the rest of the fight
scene should look like.
The movements aren't going to be exact,
but the fights have come a really,
really long way.
Tip number 18, using fast mode. There's
a new fast mode we can use inside video
3 right here that says fast text to
video. Now, this only works with the
text prompts. It's only one of the cost
as using a regular high quality model.
So, I animated some fight scenes using
this fast mode model. The motions aren't
quite as dynamic as using a regular
model, but the quality is still really,
really high compared to other AI video
generators. The arms and legs and
anatomy of the character stay pretty
consistent even when they roll around.
But one limitation of fast mode is that
you can't generate character dialogue.
While it's much much cheaper and faster
and definitely worth using for the
higher quality shots that you want,
you'll still need to use a regular
high-quality model. Tip number 19,
adding camera shots and camera angles to
your prompts to get the most cinematic
looking videos. Change up the camera
shot you're looking at the character
from. For example, we can look at a
close-up shot of the character which
focuses in on his face. We were a proud
people, but under Roman rule, our
traditions are mocked, our resources
plundered. This life is unbearable. We
can take the full body shot that will
show the entire body of the character.
Generate a video of the character from a
different camera direction, like a side
profile shot. Queen Cleopatra, a ruler
of unmatched intellect and charisma who
captivated the hearts of many. and we
can pull the camera all the way back for
an extreme long shot. Use all these
different camera shots to upgrade your
storytelling. Also, think about the
camera angle that we look at the
character from. For example, if we use a
low angle shot where we're placed below
the character and looking up, it makes
them look bigger, stronger, more
powerful. If we use a high angle shot
where we're looking down at the
character, it makes them look smaller,
weaker. We can also go all the way above
them to a bird's eye view overhead shot.
In this case, you get a more objective
look over the entire environment. I'm
sure you've noticed for a lot of the
videos I just showed, it kind of looks
like a 3D video game cinematic instead
of the lifelike photorealistic
characters that I showed earlier. The
video game style does happen quite a bit
using Google V3 if especially if you try
to generate more fantasy style
characters like this Egyptian warrior.
Tip number 19 is to use a specific
keywords muted color cinematic film. So
here I generated some more videos of
that same exact character except I added
in the phrase muted colors and cinematic
film. And you'll see that his face turns
into a photorealistic looking person.
Life under Roman rule is unbearable.
They impose harsh taxes and disrespect
our traditions. We must reclaim our
freedom. So this prompt does work in
most cases. However, you are going to
run into some situations where the
characters just generated into a video
game style pretty much no matter what.
So, in those cases, I suggest you just
change your prompt and try to create
something else. Tip number 21, introduce
camera motions into your prompts. Camera
motions help you tell a much more
dynamic story. In this video, I told the
camera to tilt up from the female
character to reveal an eagle flying in
the sky.
Here's an example where I told the
camera to pan from the female character
and show a abandoned monastery far in
the distance.
By adding camera motions, we can relate
our character to the environment around
them. In this scene, I told the female
character to cut down the knight and for
the camera to zoom in on her face during
the battle. It actually looks like it
swaps in between. So, it starts with the
two of them fighting and then it swaps
directly to her face. This can happen if
you try to introduce a lot of camera
motion into your videos. Tip number 22.
Combine different camera shots, camera
angles, and camera movements together
for the most action-packed videos. In
this case, I started with a close-up
shot on the character's face, and then I
told the camera to pull back to reveal
her riding on a horse. Here's another
example that combines a bunch of
different movements together. I asked
for a slow crane shot behind the female
character, walking up the steps of an
ancient castle. Then the camera flies
above and slowly tilts down to reveal
the entire castle. By starting with a
shot of the character and then zooming
out to reveal the entire castle, we're
able to demonstrate the scale of the
landscape and environment compared to
how small that the character is. Tip
number 23, change the camera lens or the
device that you're recording the video
from. For example, a fisheye lens.
That's an extra wide angle camera that's
going to create these distorted
spherical effects. Switch up the exact
type of camera that you're using
depending on the visual aesthetic that
you want for the video. If you use macro
lens, that's great for extreme close-up
shots, especially of very, very small
subjects with fine details. We can also
prompt for an infrared camera as well.
Tip number 24. You can create a
firsterson point of view short film
using Google V3. All we need to do is
add the words firsterson POV shot to our
prompts. In this case, I'm going to show
a point of view of a character running
through a trench in World War I.
This is a really unique way for
storytelling using a video. It's a very,
very immersive film style that puts the
viewer directly in the character shoes.
You can taste how bland these beings are
when looking at this video.
But let's go to some happier times
before the war.
Tip number 25. change up the movie genre
that you use in your prompts to
completely change the style of the
videos. PI created a group of friends
sitting around a table inside a horror
movie. Now, I'm not sure why this looks
like a Harry Potter movie because those
weren't horror movies. But if we compare
this shot to the same exact scene
generated for a comedy movie, it's a
completely different vibe. The lighting
and colors are much more lighthearted
than a comedy. Here's what it looks like
when I generated the same scene inside a
sci-fi movie.
Okay, I'm not sure what's going on
there. Maybe they're playing some
futuristic game. Changing up the movie
genre is a great way to switch up the
visual style and also the colors that we
see inside the video. Tip number 26. You
can create the AI videos with different
animation styles. So, here's a video of
the robot scavenging through a crash
landing in the normal cinematic video
style, but we can also generate that
same exact video using a 3D Pixar style.
For example, this one has a cute looking
robot typical of a Pixar movie. Now,
when it comes to creating different
animation styles, for example, in an
anime scene, make sure you put the
animation style you want at the start of
the prompt. This one I specifically told
it to create a 2D anime and I put that
keyword at the beginning of the prompt.
So Google Veil 3 does weigh the style
keywords you use at the beginning of the
prompt more heavily than the ones you
use towards the end of the prompt. So if
you want a specific style, try to put
them more towards the start of the
prompt.
Tip number 27, use different lighting
styles and also color palettes in your
videos. Lighting can make a huge
difference whether you're using soft
sunlight beaming through the trees or if
we have harsher moonlight casting down
on our characters in the middle of the
night. Adding different light sources,
for example, we can have light shining
on him from a fire.
Now, the color grading of the video can
also make a big difference in the way
that the videos look. You can use cool
blue color tones, and it creates a much
more cold and dreary feeling video.
Try using warmer colors for something
that feels a little softer and more
approachable. I personally love using
desaturated colors, which you're seeing
in movies like Saving Private Ryan, and
it gives a more gritty type of feeling
to the film. Monochromatic color schemes
where you only use one color shade like
green are also popular. This green color
gives off an uneasy and unnatural
feeling to the viewer. But we can go
with something that's much more
colorful. For example, light pastel
color tones that have soft pinks and
soft blues. Tip number 28, making
infinite looping videos. So, inside the
app itself, there isn't actually a way
to create an infinite looping video. But
let's say I want to take this video I
have of the jellyfish in this plastic
injection machine which I actually found
using FL TV and I want to create an
infinite looping video of this specific
shot. Then we can put that video inside
a video editor. Now let's copy that and
paste it so we get two shots of that
same exact video next to each other. And
what we're going to do with a second
shot is actually reverse it. So, I'm
using the Cap Cut video editor. Uh, this
is what the reverse button looks like.
And what it'll do is play the video clip
backwards. So, now that we've reversed
the second video clip, when we put them
next to each other, it's going to create
an infinite loop. And we can stack as
many of these video clips next to each
other as we want for a long infinite
looping video.
Tip number 29. Use the image generator
inside Google Veil 3 to create previews
for what your video looks like before
generating them. If we go to the frames
to video feature and we click on this
add an image, we've been uploading the
images ourselves so far, but it can
actually generate an image also. So,
let's tell it to generate a photo. Photo
of a panther
in a jungle. Golden afternoon
light and shadows. Green foliage shot on
a Sony camera. and it'll generate a set
of preview images for us that we can
pick and choose from. But some of them
are a bit closer, some of them are taken
from a bit farther back. Um, we also see
a few different camera angles, slightly
different color palettes. The point is,
if you use this feature, it'll give you
an idea of what your video is going to
look like before you generate it. And
now we can go ahead and use this image
to turn it into a video. Uh, he quietly
stalks in the forest. Let's create that.
Using a reference image first gives us a
little more control over what the final
video looks like.
Tip number 30. Creating longer videos
inside Veil 3. So inside Veil 3, we can
use this add to scene feature. And
inside here, we do have the option to
extend the video. So, let's say the
totems lapse onto the ground and break
apart.
Now, if we try to generate that, you'll
see this error again that says switching
into a compatible model for this
feature. Unfortunately, this feature
also only works for the older Google V2
model. But let's see what happens if we
generate this. Okay, so if we look at
the extended video, it does kind of
follow my prompt. the totems in the
distance break apart a little bit and
collapse. The problem is that it is the
older Veil 2 model, so the quality won't
be as good and also it's not able to
generate any sound effects. So that
means you'll need adding the sound
effects by yourself later on. If you
want a deep dive into how to best use
Google Vo3 to create the most cinematic
looking AI films, go watch this tutorial
right here.
[Music]